This was a gift from
the head of my makeup department
Her name is Debbie Zoller.
Thank you, Debbie.
I'm looking to the reflection.
Thank you, Debbie, very much for my shirt.
I told you it would come in handy
and I think
brings out the green under my eyes.
Welcome back everyone
James Gunn just announced
a bunch of new major characters
in his rebooted DC universe
that are going to be in Superman Legacy.
and a good portion of them
are basically going
to be on that new Justice League team
that he's slowly putting together.
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
Even though there is a strike going on
right now.
Everything is pretty much paused.
all the stuff that's coming out
this year is still coming out just fine.
There'll be more DC announcements,
but they aren't casting any more people
while the strike is going on.
Like they just paused
a bunch of big movies
that they're in the middle of filming
right now.
Don't worry, I'll explain
that as we go along.
Like that'll probably continue
for the next couple of months
before it actually clears up.
But you probably saw all the announcements
over the past few days.
James Gunn.
Pretty much made them quickly
before the actors strike began.
That was the whole point,
is that he wanted to make all the casting
announcements
before the actors strike started.
but all the characters
they were casting for Superman Legacy,
all these major characters will be
featured in some way during that movie.
Some will probably just have a few scenes
like minor characters.
Some will be bigger characters,
but not all of them
will be on the new Justice
League team, Like
you couldn't ever aspire to be Superman
because you had to be from Krypton.
So the idea that you could be be singled
out, that there'd be something special
about you,
you could always going to have that
in the back of your head like I could.
So potentially it could be me
if I was cool enough and, you know,
relaxed enough and was good enough
a you know, a good person.
Yeah, it could be me.
I could I could be, you know, potentially
singled out to have a ring of power
one day or maybe some kind of bandana
or a wristband, maybe some boots,
whatever it might be.
I'll take it.
probably the biggest.
And this is a super deep
cut paying off a long running fan theory
going back like 20 years.
Nathan Fillion will be
one of the new Green Lanterns.
But the big surprise
is that he's playing Guy Gardner
so if you remember his character
from Guardians of the Galaxy three,
who's kind of an asshole,
imagine him being a little bit
more like that in the DC Universe
with the Green Lantern ring
now he has played
Hal Jordan Green Lantern before,
But that was in the Emerald Dawn movie
Years and years ago after the Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern happened.
So the funny thing there is
that there had been a fan theory about him
being an awesome manager.
Like he'd be amazing as Green Lantern
going back to his days on Firefly.
Like that's
how long this fan theory gone on.
but then the studio cast Ryan Reynolds.
We know how that went down.
He's been making fun of his time
as Green Lantern for a year
through all the Deadpool movies
And since then, Nathan Fillion has played
multiple DC characters
also in live action for James
Gunn and been in a ton of live action
Marvel movies.
James Gunn put him in pretty much
every single one of his Guardians
of the Galaxy movies.
Now, a lot of his scenes
in Guardians of the Galaxy
two about are being deleted, but
he has been in each three of those movies.
So now that James Gunn is basically
running DC and doing Superman Legacy,
he has a chance to actually pay off
that long running father like, yes,
Nathan Fillion would be in awesome
Green Lantern,
but he's kind of slowly
aged out of Hal Jordan
because it sounds like the version
of how Jordan
the James Gunn wants to eventually show up
will be a little bit younger.
But it sounds like they're totally fine
with an older guy.
Gardner before that,
I was using a Green Lantern wallet.
That was last week.
I used a Green Lantern wallet
and then I wore a Green Lantern shirt
two days before that and flash underwear
about four weeks ago.
think there's going to be more
bigger stuff.
You know, just it's going to apply to more
than just my underwear.
I think I'll be able to go out
and actually do some stuff that'll be fun.
Ever see this thing on YouTube?
The Green Lantern trailer
that somebody put it?
She saw that
and thought it was pretty clever.
And so gave me the shirt.
the fan trailer that he was talking about
during his interview there was released
back in 2009, long before the Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern movie came out.
For a long time when he was younger.
Like I said, back in the Firefly days,
people wanted him as Green Lantern.
So funny that that came out years
before Ryan Reynolds, Green Lantern.
even though I love to see Ryan Reynolds
clowning on himself
about the Green Lantern movie, don't
you wish you had seen the live action?
Nathan Fillion,
Hal Jordan Green Lantern movie.
no. James Gunn didn't say what?
Nathan Fillion's Guy Gardner is going
to be doing during Superman Legacy.
But my assumption,
just based on the plot of the movie
so far that we know, is that
the main villain will be from outer space.
And that's why the Green Lantern Corps
gets involved.
Right now, the rumor is that it might wind
up being Brainiac is the main villain.
Now, Lex Luther
is obviously a big character in the movie,
but they're setting him up
just as a background antagonist
in a bigger villain in future movies.
they also just announced
that Metamorphosis
is going to be played by Anthony Carrigan,
who is also in the Gotham Series, too.
So another DC actor coming back
is a much bigger character in the movies.
he's probably going to be a minor
antagonist
in the movie, like Superman fights
a bunch of lesser villains,
and then you have your bigger villain
like Brainiac
And here's the other reminder to James
Gunn also confirmed that all the new
DC actors, regardless of who they're
playing like heroes, villains, whatever,
how big their characters are,
how small their characters are,
We'll play their characters in the movies
and come back as their characters
in all the big budget HBO DC series
that they're doing.
for example, Nathan Fillion's Guy
Gardner will debut in Superman Legacy,
but he's also going to come back
during the Green Lantern HBO series,
which is like True Detective in the DC
Universe, according to James Gunn.
The next thing is a big premiere
HBO television series called Lantern.
This is a story of a couple of Green
Lanterns, Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan.
And we have a few other lanterns
peppered in there.
But this is really a terrestrial
based TV show, which is almost like true
detective with a couple of green lanterns
who are space cops
watching over precinct Earth.
In it, they discover a terrifying mystery
that ties into our larger
story of the DCU.
The difference with the Green Lantern
HBO series
is it'll be more of an Earth based.
There is not space based.
how Jordan and Jon Stewart
working to uncover a larger mystery
that will culminate in the new Justice
League movie
that they actually wind up
doing in several years.
in, as you probably guessed,
one of the other major reasons
why James Gunn is setting up
Justice League stuff so early in Superman
Legacy is doing things more like Marvel
did in Phase one, slowly
putting together their Avengers team
so that when they actually do
the movie, people have lived
with the characters for years.
actually taking the time
to develop the characters
before you do your big team Up movie,
which was the big criticism
of the last Justice League movie
where the studio was basically like,
You know what? We had two movies.
We need our Justice League movie
to come out right now.
the next big Justice League character
and Superman legacy is going to be
Hawkgirl, played by Isabella Hammer, said
she's not connected to the black Adam
version of Hawkman as far as I know.
I don't expect that Hawkman to come back
the way that everybody's been talking
about the Black Adam movie is that most of
those characters will not come back,
particularly the rock as Black Adam
James
Gunn did not say what Hawkgirl is doing
in Superman Legacy
or how big her character is going to be.
the other new Justice
League character is Mr.
Terrific, played by Eddie. Get that guy.
Most of you will remember him
as Darwyn from X-Men First Class.
The big joke with his character.
The people were clowning on that movie
for was it?
They killed off the one character
who was supposed to be unkillable,
talk about seven degrees of bacon to Kevin
Bacon played the villain in that movie.
He was also just in James Gunn's holiday
special for Guardians of the Galaxy
as himself during that holiday special
he also made a big Batman joke
that was
probably after James Gunn
knew that he was going to get the DC job.
most of you
remember that
Arrow did a version of Mister Terrific,
but he was meant to be
a little bit different. He was like Mr.
Terrific brother Curtis Holt, the real Mr.
Terrific name is Michael Holt.
James
Gunn is doing the real version of Mr.
Terrific, not the Wal-Mart version of Mr.
Terrific.
now a lot of you
probably saw these casting announcements
and realize what James Gunn is doing
with his new Justice League
team, just based on some of the characters
he's casting.
It looks like his new Justice League team
will be based on the animated version
of the Justice League team.
Now, it's not going to be the exact same,
but it'll be pretty close.
Like we have the usual
main Superman Batman
who will meet in Batman
and Brave in the Bold
in a couple of years.
Wonder Woman. but.
It looks like we might wind up
getting a Wally West version of The Flash,
which funny enough, Michael Rosenbaum,
longtime James Gunn collaborator Lex
Luthor himself in Smallville was also
the voice of this version of The Flash
on the Animated Justice League.
And it was a while ago.
But you played Lex Luthor on Smallville.
My dad.
He might.
There's a chance
he could get confused and attack you.
I don't want you to worry about that.
I was the voice of the
Flash for ten years.
Wait,
How did I miss that?
Remember when they did the DC TV crisis
on Infinite Earths?
I was hoping so bad that he would cameo,
but not as his Lex Luther
because they did Tom Welling Superman.
I was hoping the surprise would be
is that his cameo would actually be
as a live action version of his Wally West
James Gunn just did a big interview
talking about his new DC Universe,
the new DC movie Superman Legacy
with Michael Rosenbaum on his podcast.
And during that
he also said that he was one of the best
Lex Luther's of all time
totally agree with him.
Definitely. Michael Rosenbaum
one of the best.
Lex's maybe, maybe in like ten or 12
years, Michael Rosenbaum will come back.
Is his version of Lex in like a big crisis
on Infinite Earths movie?
but it does sound like he's
trying to angle for some kind of cameo
seen as a lesser character
the way he did in
James
Gunn's Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
so if he does come back somewhere
in the new DC movies or the new DC
HBO series, it'll probably be
as a completely different character.
looking at the rest of this animated
Justice League team, James Gunn also made
it seem like he would be doing
Martian Manhunter in his new movies.
And Jon Stewart
will meet during the Green Lantern series.
the final roster for his new Justice
League team might be a little different,
but does it not seem like his new team
will be more like the animated version
of the Justice League team that also help
it feel completely distinct
like totally different vibe from Zack
Snyder's version of Justice League.
Obviously there are a bunch of other
huge roles that James Gunn
has to announce for Superman Legacy
that we don't know about yet.
I've already done a much bigger video
on David Corenswet's Superman
and the other actors like Lois Lane
that they just announced.
You can click here to watch that
and click here for my new Deadpool
3 video of Wolverine versus Deadpool
in a whole bunch of Loki crossover
Easter eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!